[Music]
am i supposed to feel ready yeah but
i guess
when you prepare for such a major event
you always
feel like you
could could do more
but i guess we are doing some
insane amount of work so
i hope we we got to be you know
ready enough
that's it's
that's really uh
i don't know i i can't say i have like
some some habitu or something so
sometimes sometimes i feel like i'm like
in a sleepy mood or something and then
i'm listening to some
you know some hard rock music or
something
so to
to feel the energy i feel the power but
i mean in general it's
i mean it really depends on the mood and
the mood can be
different yeah
from from one day to another since
it's not some kind of a ritual i'm
trying to stick to
being lazy probably that's that's my
superpower
i think uh it plays its own role but
it's you know it's i mean if
trying to be serious it's hard to
evaluate because
i think in modern shares you got to be
a very universal player if you want to
be successful and you can't rely on the
intuition alone so it's
they would like to you know to say that
for example
uh a player a world champion with the
best intuition ever is michelle tyle but
i guess he also had you know
he he had to calculate a lot here and
for example today if you
if you try to to stick to his playing
style it would be
sometimes it would be very costly to to
your performance so i think yeah the
intuition is it's always good but
i mean sometimes you basically can't
choose the move uh
because of your calculation or a
violation and you need to for example
sometimes you are giving like two
similar opportunities and you you you
get a big one
and okay probably here the institution
comes
i guess it's uh
lies you know somewhere in the future
i'd probably stick to the same uh answer
because uh when they i mean okay that's
not
you know that's not anything special
about the match but in general
when they say what's your biggest
tournament success or something i always
try to say that okay i still hope that
it's still you know it's still ahead
i guess it's an improvement uh
for sure because
it gives you more chances to play some
good chance and
i don't think i i don't feel it's some
completely different story like it's not
like
uh
as they used to play like karpov against
kasparov until someone hits six
victories or it wasn't like it's not
like
for example in 1972 spassky against
fisher 24 games so in general
it's
it's of course more interesting and
i think this came as a price uh
the price was probably not too high
removing some extra residue
i guess yeah it probably would change uh
something uh
perhaps closer to the
[Music]
final part of the match here because
once people get tires they
they normally you you you know they
normally play worse but
you know you never know until it until
it will happen
in general i don't feel some major
difference
well i
didn't
use my chance to try this bot but i
played against some other bots so
well
hopefully i won't lose to
too badly uh to this you know artificial
intelligence
you know as they say
but in general yeah it just comes
probably the
[Music]
the best uh
chess
portal right now at the moment and it's
very friendly to all
all sort of just players you know
especially to casual chess players also
you know there are a lot of
nice events for
professionals and for
those who only try to make that you know
make their own way to the top
and i guess especially
in the
it wasn't uh in 2020 then it was
almost no
online events i mean necessary you know
almost no events uh you know over the
board you know have an opportunity to
play time to use the
uh
every tuesday
yeah uh is i mean okay uh of course
there were
you know there was all this controversy
because it was held online but in
general i think it was very supportive
towards players so you can
you know even in these dire times
you could uh
earn like your chess and you could
play some competitive chess and of
course
you know some other
projects which
are
you know
which
probably invites more and more people to
to join the chess families it's also
like it's
it's very nice yeah so basically we are
all doing the you know
the same thing and we have the same goal
i really i honestly don't know what
transfer so
normally
we all we all want to remember only good
things here so i think it would be
enough
enough good stuff to remember
over nine thousands
well i'm
preparing for the chest boxing a lot so
i think
i i know i'd
i'd have a good chance
[Music]
well i
can't really remember all uh all the
finesses of this question so first of
all
what music
any music
literally any music so i'm
it depends on my mood
then movie
i guess the best one uh
of which i
which i have seen recently was
another round
we've met mikkelsen
and among all times
my favorite movie i guess is the reader
then what some food
well
any food
probably
mostly
some meat or some italian cuisine
and what else a book
on drinks of course tea come on i come
from russia
we all drink tea here yeah okay some
some also drink vodka but
uh this is uh you know these times are
probably not for what okay not yet
uh for now it's tea time and uh
book probably i can't pick one but
from
russian
writers i think i prefer anton chekhov
and from
let's see all over the world i think it
would be burgess
how do you enjoy your free time if there
is any free time
which free time free time what what's
free time do you have any free time what
do i what is free time sorry
it was supposed to be a joke until you
uh i asked to ask an extra question
yeah
i think i i i used to be like this yeah
and i was
one of my first
coaches told me okay it's very normal
that you get to play in the same
or let's say same short here if you the
tournament is going all right okay you
don't change anything in your daily
routine in your daily routine but uh in
general i have found a lot of um
[Music]
arguments for the both uh
for the both takes on this uh
this you know superstition so for
example
yeah sometimes you really follow okay if
a tournament is okay if it's going uh
great uh
probably i would say you can do whatever
you want yeah just don't don't try to
harm you know the way you you work your
you know the way the way you play the
way the the way you prepare
but uh if the tournament is bad
it's very likely
nothing will help you yes
you can choose like 10 different
you you can change
your clothes for 10 times and change
your pen or something but it would
hardly ever take any serious effect
so it's
in general you got to be more realistic
but
yeah when
you know it's good to
you know discuss like this and you're
not involved into any tournament but
during the tournament uh okay it's
it can be very different i believe so
and
but
well
let's see what happens
[Music]
you